[Music]
[Music]
we're about to start 7c
hello everyone and welcome to the
opening ceremony of the st. Louis rapid
and blitz here at the world chess Hall
of Fame in beautiful st. Louis I'm
Maurice Ashley and I'm pleased to
welcome some of the greatest players on
the planet as they come to do battle
once again for this the fourth stop on
the grand chest tour of 2019
of course none of this would be possible
without the wonderful kindness
generosity largesse and vision of two
great people and if you please give a
hand to dr. Jeanne Singh field and Rex
Sinquefield for everything they do for
check we'd like to thank Shannon for her
leadership here at the world chess all
the fame and our great team always it's
incredible how much we get love here
there's so much great support for the
staff for everyone here for the
commentators with players for the
visitors simply incredible that st.
Louis is really a jewel for chess in the
world and please thank them for all the
hard work that they do none of this
would happen without the vision of folks
who decided that the Grantchester was a
great idea and four years running it
certainly has proven itself as such it's
kind of funny it started with only three
chess events now we're at eight it's the
money is growing the players have grown
and involved but we see all the players
participating every year so that's
validation as well we're always pleased
to see that support so it's wonderful to
see the growth happen and that happened
primarily because of the vision of one
man as well he is not in the audience
hopefully he will make it here soon I
think actually he will be here a little
bit later in the summer and that is one
garry kasparov
please give Gary and Gary wherever you
are we are very appreciative
we also have a great staff the board of
the Grantchester which includes Mike
Karthik offski Graham jürgenson Tony
rich who is not here today I'm shocked
cuz Tony is always here but he's at the
US Open
right now accepting a George Colton
auskey Gold Award being given to one dr.
ginseng field and wreck Singh field so
congratulations Jeannie and Rex on that
accomplishment a lady who never likes
the spotlight but today she's wearing
red so she must like the spotlight she's
the big dog really she's the boss
everybody listens to her even Rex is
scared of her she does she gets it all
done and we're very pleased and proud to
thank you joy brain we have our sponsors
around the world we want to thank Jill
Beth Houser of Colliers International
they just hosted a wonderful event in
Paris of course Vivendi and that
sponsors in Abidjan as well as gameplan
in India in Calcutta where we will be
also the local sponsors in Croatia also
was a fabulous event and a bucharest as
well so we're appreciative of our
sponsors and with that I will give the
microphone over to a lady who really
needs no introduction dr. Jeannie Singh
field well this has really gotten crazy
when we started this how many years has
it been now five six six years you make
us so proud to have the best chess
players in the world it's really cool so
and Rex they said we got an award I
actually got another award
I'm the best-selling chess author at the
world chess Hall of Fame
see that's because my book my booklet is
only 12 pages long and it teaches you
how to learn to read and write chess so
anyway my job is always to introduce Rex
so I'm always trying to figure out you
know I'm always competing with you know
how this competition goes he goes hi and
I go low so I'm teaching you how to read
and write and 250,000 boys who now can
play chess in America
watch out Russia and then there's Rex so
what can you say about Rex and he's
coming over to take this away and he's
trying to prevent me from saying
wonderful things but I guess since I
want to stay married I should say
positive things so so the Godfather of
American chess Rex Sinquefield Thank You
Jeanne welcome to all of these wonderful
players to st. Louis again this is
definitely my favorite event of year and
time of the year as the world's best
players come to st. Louis so let's give
the players a big round of applause and
appreciation
[Applause]
now we're excited to announce that
Grandmaster Lanier Dominguez not only
changed his Federation from Cuba to the
United States earlier this year but he's
also officially moved to st. Louis last
weekend and now calls st. Louis home and
I have checked with Mayor Lyta cruson
and she tells me officially that all of
your other grandmasters are welcome to
move here as well so first I want to
recognize the our life our commentators
the English team grandmasters Yasir Sara
Juan Maurice Ashley and Jennifer
Shahadah the online Russian team even a
metal shinny Jenko mural Meryl do huh
and Amira
script chenko and the live audience
commentary a kingside diner will be
Grandmaster Christian sherrilyn who is
now the new chess coach of the
University of Missouri chess team Howl's
in Columbia Missouri and GM Alejandro
Ramirez the chess coach at Saint Louis
University
so with that Missouri now has four
scholarship based collegiate chess teams
Webster College Lindenwood college st.
Louis University and the University of
Missouri so today
Missouri tomorrow out of the world all
right so the staff of the Chess Club and
world chess Hall of Fame really worked
so well together and worked so hard to
do a phenomenal job day in and out and
to prepare for all of this I especially
want to thank our great overseer joy
Bray she can't be thanked enough for
everything she does and to Tony rich the
executive director of the club Shannon
Bailey the chief curator of this world
chess Hall of Fame and all of their
staff were the tremendous organization
that leads to so much great success I
also want to thank all of our
contractors and vendors who are
essential for this Randy and his team at
Spectrum Steve studios kita and his crew
at silverback Studios Erik Mosul who
designs and creates all of the graphics
for the show and the production teams
throughout the year Ben Simon and Isaac
France who are handling the production
for the Russian commentary and all those
that make all the broadcasts and live
show an incredible success and before I
introduced the next speaker I want to
tell you about some chess tables I know
you're wondering what's the next
exciting topic well it's chess tables
what could be more exciting than that
some years ago Jeanne and I met a young
fellow 16 years old name was Nate Cohen
and it still is but we were building a
house in Central Missouri and he decided
I wanted a good chess table and so one
was designed by who was the design Nate
the first one oh yeah okay Thomas Moser
and then we met Nate and we said can you
make a table like this and he said yeah
I think I can so he made some and we
liked them and then we started getting
more and more of them here at the Chess
Club and everybody refers to them as the
Nate Cohen tables which is appropriate
Nate also has won three international
competitions for woodworking he is an
incredible
expert and Mike Matheny who many of you
know it was the manager of the st. Louis
Cardinals is also professional
woodworker and he saw Nate's tables when
we put them in the st. Louis Cardinal
locker room he turned them over and he
said this guy is off the charts good and
he really is so after years of Grand
Master's playing on those I was inspired
by the Cuban table that we have here
that was used in 1960 and 66 in Havana
and I really like the look of it and the
feel of it and everything so we went to
Nate and said can you make something
like this
and we talked to the staff Jeannie and I
talked to everybody got their input and
he did do it and in my script says the
sink filled tables were born
that's baloney these are the Nate Cohen
tables reborn so first I want to
introduce Nate say a few words and then
we will that new table over there Nate
[Applause]
well thank you Rex and I just gotta say
it is an honor to be here tonight and
I'm so excited that for the very first
time that these tables gonna be used is
by some of the finest swell the finest
players in the world so I'm so excited
for that like Rick said these were
inspired by the Bobby Fischer table or
the the Cuban table the Bobby Fischer
played on in 66 but they've got a twist
of today's technology in them so I'm
going to tell you a quick story and Rex
alluded to it a little bit but I met
Jeanie 13 years ago and out of the
farmhouse I was 16 years old at the time
I didn't play chess but later they asked
me to build a chess table for Rex and so
at the time no I didn't play chess I
knew very little about it if someone
would ask me how many squares on a
chessboard I could have said in fact I
actually referred to it as a
checkerboard and Tony later corrected me
it was embarrassing but I put my mind to
it and we figured it out so I delivered
the first table Jeannie loved it Rex
loved it and over the years I've had
many more
but what one thing that I've learned is
most people want to be part of something
that's bigger than themselves and I had
no idea that it's 16 years old it was by
baking this chess table that it would
lead to an opportunity later on to be
part of something that was what we've
come into here with this st. Louis chess
campus and and and this is a place where
literally thousands of lives around the
world not just in the st. Louis
community but around the world we got so
many people here and so many people
watching that their lives have been
changed and improved because of what's
happening here and I'm so excited to get
to play a small part in that by
providing all the chess tables that the
mayor the major tournaments that the
club puts on so I'm grateful and I want
to thank you Jeanie and Rex Sinquefield
for allowing me to be part of this
amazing chess family
[Applause]
okay who's supposed to be okay you ready
this is the unveiling of the Nate :
the new Nate : tables you guys will
probably fall asleep resting on that
yeah unfortunately it's got 68 squares I
don't know what we're gonna do about
that okay Thank You Maurice Thank You
Rex thank you Jeannie thank you Nate
always pushing the envelope here in the
club all right now it's time to get down
to the true stars of the event the
players themselves some of the greatest
players on the planet and I'd like to
introduce all of them first to give a
chance to give a real warm hand of
applause to these great gladiators I
will start in the front
first of all shock rearmament iran from
azerbaijan from Russia Sergey Carr yakun
Levon Aronian
dare I say from the United States by way
of Cuba Lanier Dominguez from China
welcome to st. Louis you young ye from
France Maxime by Sheila Grove from the
United States
Fabiano Caruana
[Music]
make a slight alteration in my order
from China
ding Lauren and of course the gentleman
who deserves no introduction the world
champion from Norway Magnus Carlsen
[Applause]
these are indeed the great superstars
we're gonna have great fun with the
rapid and blitz event I do get to ask a
question and I was thinking what's the
question that's on everybody's mind and
this will be an interesting one for the
players I should also point out sorry
that Richard rapport from Hungary will
be playing unfortunately his flight had
a problem cancelled and it got
rescheduled so he will be here to play
we will have indeed 10 players not 9 but
Richard will be here so question for the
players everybody is wondering the
answer to this question and we're gonna
start with you being what's it gonna
take to stop Magnus Carlsen could you
please say well I should preface my
question one player has been playing
extremely well he's won everything that
he's played in this year and I know he
has the shoulders through to deal with
everybody paying attention to him right
at this moment was it such a direct
question and the question is what is it
going to take to stop the world champion
from winning this st. Louis rapid and
blades first I had to survive my own
game against him last time I lost to him
with white pieces so I have to do better
and then my business
please chakra are same question I don't
think about it first I think how to stop
Fabiana this book ID after Magnus but I
think his of course he prover well of
course very good here and but were not
forget he lost was gave me okay I think
to play again we say every time before
the tournament we will try but it's not
helping but I hope this time thank you
Sergey yeah well he had a fantastic here
there is nothing to say what my answer
might be primitive but we should play
well yeah I don't think it's so much
about stopping somebody but just about
achieving more points than the person
mmm-hmm there's a concentrate on scoring
more points and looking at somebody else
yeah I think if we would know the answer
things would have been different yeah
the first part of the year probably
takes some good moves but you have to do
it like consistently and fortunately
it's not so easy
I think Magnus is for the best
maybe I think maybe Magnus mistake
yes thank you so the only way I know how
to win a tournament 100 points in bit
yeah it's difficult to follow up after
seven grandmasters but I think it's sort
of a mistake to only think about one
player and forget about everyone else
anyone here could win the tournament
Magnus I mean I think a lot of wise
things have have been said and I think
every tournament sort of has its own has
its own life I think it's it's it's an
advantage of having had a good run of
success recently it makes you more you
more comfortable more confident and also
maybe your opponents less comfortable
and less confident so yeah I think there
are advantages to it but yeah most of
all you you have to play well and I
think once I start playing poorly again
people will will smell blood so it won't
be easy thank you Magnus appreciate it
well it is that time the players want
the most so I will get there
it's the drawing of lots who plays whom
with white with black and for that I
will introduce our chief our to be Chris
Byrd Thank You Maurice I'm gonna move to
this place for you so I can safeguard
all these first of all I would like to
introduce I can't do the whole work for
the whole week by myself so I'd like to
introduce the two assistant arbiters
Karen Pennock and Enrique Reuter also
just want to mention a little bit about
what's gonna be going on over the next
week the format of the tournament which
you're all hopefully gonna get to watch
either in person or online so we're
gonna have these guys are going to
battle it out over the next five days
three days of rapid chess three games a
day and then the where they'll score two
points for a win one for a tie and 0 for
a loss and then they'll follow that up
with two grueling days of blitz where
they'll play 18 games in total scoring a
point for a win half a point for a draw
and 0 for a loss and hopefully at the
end of that we'll have a clear winner if
not I guess we'll have some Thai brat
games to follow that which will be very
exciting as well so to help us get on
the way with the tournament we have to
do the drawing of lots so we have two
sets of ten gifts we have look I'm going
to actually have Maurice call the
players up in his random order the
players will first select a box from the
rapid set pick they're a pairing number
four there and then also they will pick
a pairing number for the blitz which is
maybe a little less important since
that's a double round-robin they'll get
to play everyone with white and black
two so Maurice if you'd like to go ahead
thank you so much crazy my random order
is gonna start not so randomly with the
world champion Magnus Carlsen
[Applause]
naturally the other way it's number six
number six and for the Blitz it's number
five Thank You Magnus will continue in
clockwise order
Fabiano Caruana and that's number eight
get to keep that and for the Blitz
that's number one thank you
and next Maxime by Sheila Grove and
that's number two for the rapid and
that's number six for the Blitz and next
up you young that's number one for the
rapid
and that's number two for the Blitz
linear and if I may just add if you
don't mind you need a photo here and
also please show the audience and I
neglected that and that's number seven
number seven for the rapid thank you
very well done and for the Blitz that's
number three Thank You LaVon you're up
next he did a good job so let's see you
follow up on that and that is them
benign for the rapid you didn't show
them anything I want to see the number
there you go and there too
there you go you got it and for the
Blitz it's number four well executed sir
well done and this is the one there's no
three-card Monte working okay all right
it is Sergei you're up next
[Laughter]
and that's number three for the rapid
and that's number seven for the Blitz
number three correct okay there you go
Thank You Sergei Thank You Jacques we
are that's number four for the rapid and
number eight for the Blitz thank you and
ding number five for the rapid and
that's number nine for the Blitz thank
you and Chris if you made for Richard
please
and for Richard we have number 10 for
the rapid and I think we have number 10
for the blitz fixes it hitch it is not
going to believe this yeah don't miss
your flights man that's wrong that is
the end of my magic show well I believe
you have pairings ready for the first
round of the rapids your able assistance
if you will please read those pairings
the beginning of tomorrow is first game
ok so we should have you Yangyi should
have white against Richard rapport
Maxine viola graph will have white
against Levon Aronian Sega kayaking will
have white against Fabiano Kurata number
four Shaq mogera
will have white against
Alania Dominguez and that should leave
me ding Lorraine to have white against
magnus carlsen some great pairings thank
you very much Chris
well as you said we've had three
exciting events so far this year in
Abidjan we at our visit to the African
continent this the country of Cote
d'Ivoire they welcomed us quite well and
magnus carlsen won that event we then
moved on to a new stop in zagreb for the
classical event great location as well
great lovers of chess there in Croatia
Magnus won that event as well we then
moved on to Paris and of course it's
Paris so spectacular location right off
the shores it is a and the Parisian the
homeboy took home the event Maxime
vasila Grove to the delight of the
Parisian fans what will happen here in
st. Louis we don't know as Christiane
Carillo says only time will tell
and we are looking forward to that will
be providing commentary the great team
of of Jennifer and Yassir we keep
ourselves laughing the whole time but
also we have so much fun because the
players are playing wonderful moves and
it's always exciting and as Rex
mentioned all the other great
commentators as well and also like to
mention VAR a Cobian will be in the
truck letting us know where the good
moves are and where the mistakes are not
too many mistakes hopefully and of
course not to have abirami on who works
the social media team and keeps everyone
around the world informed so it should
be a ton of fun we hope you will tune in
it will be live the show will start at
12:50 the online show the games begin at
1:00 p.m. Central
it'll be fun will be exciting I'm
looking forward to it so let's get the
show on the road thank you everybody and
have a good night
[Music]
[Music]
you